Hello my name is Emma, an in today's video I
am going to teach you some key expressions.
You can use when somebody tells you something that's not
true and you want to argue against what they're saying.
So, in this video I'm going to teach you these
great expressions.
But before I do that.
We're going to talk about 3 words that are very
common in English.
These days, those 3 words are fake news conspiracy theories
and hoax is so in this video you will learn
what these words mean?
And you will also learn what to say to somebody
that tells you something that's not true.
Alright so let's get started.
So I have here 3 sentence is the first sentence
is scientists say the Earth is flat,
not round. Is this true or not true?
OK, this sentence is not true some people believe this
but it is not true.
My second sentence Michael Jackson is alive and living as
Kim Kardashian.
True or not true.
Again, we have a sentence that is not true I
made this up.
And finally my third sentence listening to rock music causes
cancer is this true or untrue.
Again, this is untrue. I also made up this so
my point here is that a lot of what you
hear from people in conversation is not true.
People say, these types of things all the time and
you will know that this is something that's not true
So what do you say when someone tells you that
the earth is flat or they tell you that Michael
Jackson is living as Kim Kardashian,
so I will teach you those great expressions you can
use.
Before I do that I wanted to just say that
these 3 sentence is can also be considered fake news.
So we will look at the meaning of fake news
in a moment.
OK so the 3 main words,
I wanted to teach you today are words that you
will see a lot on the Internet and in the
media.
The first word is fake news So what is fake
news while fake means not true?
Fake news is news stories that are not true and
their created to damage a person,
a business. An agency or government or they might also
be created to get attention and to get clicks on
the Internet.
So you'll see a lot of fake news on different
social media like Twitter,
Facebook and a lot of other places to online.
So this is very common word these days a lot
of people are using it.
So it's important that you know what it means.
We also have the word here,
conspiracy theory. So a conspiracy theory.
Is an explanation? Of an event or situation that is
different from the official account alot of the Times conspiracy
theories are about government or a business doing something illegal
or to harm someone so let's think of some conspiracy
theories.
Some people believe that the moon landing.
So when when astronauts went to the moon in the
1960s.
Some people believe the moon landing was fake.
This is a popular conspiracy theory.
Another conspiracy theory, I heard recently is some people believe
that Paul McCartney from The Beatles actually died in 1966
and there is a different man who replaced him and
who is actually the better musician so this is a
different conspiracy theory.
So you'll see a lot of conspiracy theories on the
Internet.
And a lot of people will tell you conspiracy theories
during conversations.
The last word I wanted to teach you was the
word hoax.
Hoax so a hoax. Is a type of practical joke
that is meant to embarrass or hurt people so some
examples of hoax?
Is our you'll have these death hoax is where they'll
say a celebrity is dead,
but it's not true, it's a joke or you might
have a hoax like some people might take a picture
of an alien or a monster and tell everyone look.
We have evidence of this monster or alien,
but if it's not true then it's.
It's a joke of practical joke.
So again fake news conspiracy theories an hoax is are
very common on the Internet and so for these things
that are not true?
What do you say to people when they tell you
this untrue information?
Well let's find out in a moment.
OK, so you've heard a fake news story or conspiracy
theory or a hoax.
Maybe your aunt or your friend just told you it
an you know it's not true So what do you
say to them?
Well, what you can do is you can challenge their
argument?
So for example, you can say.
So let me get this straight you're saying and you
can repeat what they said.
So let me get this straight you're saying Paul McCartney
died in 1966.
And then what you can say is.
And say that's not true.
That's inaccurate. I find that hard to believe.
That doesn't make sense. So these are all expressions,
we use when we're saying I don't believe you.
Now, if we wanted to say something that was a
little bit more impolite.
We can use the word BS as in that's BS.
BS stands for bullshit an sometimes we don't want to
swear so we might just say to our friends that's
total BS or that's BS.
You can also say to somebody that's ridiculous,
meaning that's that's a stupid story.
That's ridiculous it's not true.
So these are all examples of common things.
People say when someone tells them something that they don't
believe so now let's look at some other things we
can say when somebody tells us a fake news story.
OK, so another thing you can do when somebody tells
you fake news or something that's not true is you
can ask them where their sources or where did they
get the information from? So this is the big where
question when we talk about sources or new sources were
talking about who said it so for example,
maybe the news came from your mom.
So maybe that's not a great source.
Maybe it came from BBC News.
Or maybe it came from wika pedia or Facebook or
if you're in science is maybe it came from a
peer reviewed Journal.
Maybe it came from Twitter or your aunt or your
friends so it's good to ask somebody.
Where did they get the information from?
And then you can think about OK is that a
good source.
And a lot of the times it probably isn't.
And you can tell them this OK,
so if somebody tells you for example,
that the moon landing didn't happen and there's a big
conspiracy and aliens control the US and Canada and China
but you can say to them is who told you
that? Where is your news source and if they say,
Oh, my friend Gary told me that well then you
can say that's not a good news source.
You can also ask them why or how questions so
for example,
you know why would. You know.
Let's start with how. How would the government cover that
up or how would rock and roll music cause cancer
so you can always ask these questions?
Why and how an you know,
maybe they have a good explanation.
But it's good to ask these questions to find out
more about why they think what they think.
You can also counter what they're saying meaning if they
say something,
and you disagree you can say your opinion so for
example.
If somebody told you that Kim Kardashian is really Michael
Jackson.
You can say the fact of the matter is Michael
Jackson passed away.
He is not Kim Kardashian.
The truth is Michael Jackson and Kim Kardashian or not
the same person.
You can also say in reality.
In reality, Michael Jackson is not Kim Kardashian.
So these are great expressions,
you can use when you're trying to tell somebody that
what they're saying is incorrect and that what you're saying
is the correct belief.
OK so we've gone over all these different things to
say.
When somebody tells you something that's not true so let's
practice it.
OK, this just in fake news story.
Did you hear terrorists have melted Antarctica using a giant
laser OK,
so terrorists have melted Antarctica using a gigantic laser?
So that's the news story,
which I just made up.
It's fake news. So, your source is Emma.
And this is not a good source for this news
story.
So what can you say to me if I give
you a fake news story like that?
Or maybe you'll say that's not true you might say
where did you hear that Emma?
Why would terrorists melt Antarctica with a giant laser?
How would terrorists get the laser so you might ask
these questions and then you might tell me the truth.
The fact of the matter is an Arctica has not
been melted by terrorists that is fake news.
So thank you for watching I hope you've learned something
maybe about some of these words like fake news hoax
or conspiracy theory.
Also, maybe some expressions you can use when you hear
something that is untrue.
I'd like to invite you to come check out our
website at WWW dotindeed.com.
There you can actually do a quiz to practice what
you learn in this video.
I would also like to invite you to subscribe to
my channel.
You can find a lot of other resource is on
many different things about English,
including English conversation expressions vocabulary work English and a lot
more so.
Thank you for watching an until next time take care.